PROFESSOR: So as an
aside, for those of you
who have an understanding
of probability
theory and stochastic
processes, let
me just explain why it is valid
to bound the main transmission
rate in defining the indoor
reproductive number when
we might be more
concerned about bounding
the probability
of a transmission.
So let's let a capital T
be a random variable which
describes the random
number of transmissions
that occur in the room.
And this is specifically for
the case for one infector
or infected person and
n minus 1 susceptible.
So again, the situation of
the reproductive number where
for every person that
comes in we want to know
is there going to
be transmission,
and typically, only one
infected person would be seen.
So this is a random variable,
and let's let ft of n
be the probability
density function that
gives the probability of
little n transmissions.
And then we can define the risk
of a transmission, the risk
of at least one transmission,
as the probability
that this random variable
takes on a value, which
is greater than or equal to 1.
OK.
Well, in terms of the
probability density function
then, that would be a sum from
1 to infinity of the ft event,
basically.
So we're just adding
the probabilities
that we're not seeing a
transmission to those--
or possible transition to those
different numbers of people.
Now I'd like to do
a little calculation
to get an upper bound
on this quantity.
So we can say that
this is less than
or equal to the
sum from n equals 1
to infinity of n ft of n.
Now, this is just a
mathematical trick here.
So n refers to the natural
numbers 1, 2, 3, 4, et cetera.
Those are all positive
numbers and they're
all greater than or equal to 1.
So if I take 1 in this
expression over here
and replace it
with little n, I'm
only increasing the value
of that sum, because also,
this ft is a probability
density that has to be positive.
And then now I can also
say that this is actually
equal to throwing in n equals
0, because that is a term that
is actually identically 0.
So I can change the summation.
And then by definition
here, this thing
is the expected value of
the number of transmissions,
because I'm summing the
number of transmissions
little n times the probability
of that event occurring.
So that is the definition
of the average.
So what we're seeing here is
that the risk of a transmission
is rigorously bounded
above by the expected
number of transmissions.
And so therefore, if we require
that this is less than epsilon,
our risk tolerance that
we've just introduced,
this is a conservative bound
on the true risk, which let's
say here is defined by rt.
So if your goal is to control
the probability of having
at least one
transmission, so basically
to ensure that no
transmissions occur,
then you would do well to
bound the expected number
of transmissions, because
that's an upper bound.
It can also be shown
that as epsilon
goes to 0, so we're talking
about very low probabilities
of transmission, and
oftentimes that is the case,
then rt is asymptotically
the same as the expected
number of transmissions.
So this overall risk of a
transmission and the expected
number are the same.
And in fact, that's
one way to understand
sort of even the
definition of a probability
in terms of an expected
number of events.
And we are typically
thinking of cases where
epsilon is much less than 1.
So for those of you that have
some background in probability,
you may recognize that
what I've just done here
is an example of a much
more general result, which
is called Markov's Inequality.
So now we can safely
proceed by continuing
to work with average values of
all the quantities of interest.